[Music]
about three years ago I came in the big
think and I talked very strongly and
very passionately about atheism I did
not believe in God and over the past
three years I opened my heart to our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ and the
Holy Spirit filled me and all of a
sudden I realized that everlasting life
is possible by following in the ways of
Jesus Christ our Lord I have since then
dedicated my life to Jesus Christ I have
joined the church and I will live the
rest of my life and die as a Christian
in in-service and enjoy with Jesus
Christ our Lord can you imagine how much
money I would make if I could just
convert to real hard to convert if I
just pretend to convert to really can
you imagine if I just took and threw
away my atheism if I threw away my
morality and said I was I was religious
and went out and started preaching can
you imagine the amount of money I would
make but what good if a man gain the
whole world but lose his soul no I'm
still an atheist I'm still doing fine I
just spoke at a young Americans for a
Liberty Conference you know a lot of
conservatives a lot of people that are
too young be wearing suits wearing suits
I liked him and afterwards a man came up
to me probably 20 years old and he was
slight and build very dark complected
and he said to me I want to talk about
this during your lecture but I was very
very frightened that there were cameras
there and I said well there were cameras
there so at least you're not frightened
by UFOs you're frightened by spiders
something that's real I can respect that
I made this kind of light of his his
wording there
and then he shut me up because then he
said my family is from Pakistan and
everybody in my community is a devout
Muslim
and my mom and dad are divine devout
Muslims and I'm an atheist and if I said
that while you were speaking I raised my
hand and said that with the cameras on
said that declarative statement I'm an
atheist my mom and dad would not kill me
but they would disown me and they would
never speak to me again and I would be
an apostate and it is not unlikely that
someone in my community would kill me
and he didn't mean that figuratively he
didn't mean that word kill like
comedians mean it he meant they would
take his life away now I know a Yan
Hirsi Ali so I knew he wasn't bluffing
and then it got worse because then he
said and yet with my dark skin and my
straight black hair
the other side considers me Muslim and
wants to get me out of the country and
treat me badly and I hear Trump giving
his speeches against people of my
ancestry and I realize that there's
nobody for me nobody and he said I want
to talk to you because and this is him
saying this he said some stuff about me
being some you know you only wanted
would understand which is clearly not
not true everybody understand virtually
everybody understand but you know it's
an atheist Christopher Hitchens my
friend my hero my mentor even though he
wasn't much older than maybe he's so
much smarter used to say you know Pam if
you dislike Christianity you must
dislike Islam much more now I want to be
very careful about this Islamophobia is
the wrong word Islam is an idea
Muslims are people you are allowed to
hate ideas you're allowed to disagree
with ideas you are not allowed to hate
people for their ideas it's the wrong
word it's just the wrong word we have to
be more careful Islamophobia is not
racism saying anything against Muslims
is you can say Christianity is wrong and
have friends who are Christian you can
show full respect for Christians you're
not you know you're not Christianity a
phobic you know you're just saying no I
have a different idea that's what
America is and I believe my feelings as
an atheist change somewhat when that man
speaks to me because
because of my heart yes
Islam is wrong yes
Christianity is wrong yes
Judaism is wrong I believe that like I
believe I breathe I don't doubt that
ever
but right now Muslims those who believe
in Islam really need our help
there's refugees who are suffering in a
way that history will not be kind to us
for ignoring that we must love them we
must embrace them we must help them even
if they believe things that we know are
wrong
the chances of a terrorist believing in
Islam are pretty good the chances of
someone who believes in Islam being a
terrorist are very very bad very little
chance of that we took into Nevada I
live in Nevada we took nine people from
Syria in the entire state of Nevada
that's how many were built nine the
number of fingers Jerry Garcia had nine
nine next stage is gonna be Jerry Garcia
I think it's nine nine no is this a nine
Jerry Garcia is not a part of this
discussion Penn get on with him nine
nine nine Jerry Garcia nine Jerry nine
not nine families nine people Nevada
it's a state you know we've got to help
those people now how do i as an atheist
say to Muslims your religion is wrong
you're terrorists are crazy
this is dangerous get over it and then
say I love you and you're welcome
really
really hard I gotta tell you I know
there's no God and because there's no
God we have to reach out to Muslims we
have to do God's work as God's not going
to and that love and that compassion is
not going to come from Allah and it's
not gonna come from yet law it's not
gonna come from Jesus Christ that love
and compassion is gonna come from us is
it dangerous to embrace Muslims because
some of them would be terrorists yeah
it's really dangerous do we have to
protect ourselves yeah we really do
there's hard problems here really hard
problems and I don't have any of the
answers to it but I'll tell you what the
answer isn't the answer isn't standing
up with a hair that looks like cotton
can be made of piss and saying you know
we got to keep these people out of here
we're gonna keep these people out of
here I cannot fight anyway that
preaching hate helps that situation and
I defy you no matter how afraid you are
of of terrorists to look at that man and
I'm so glad I don't remember his name
I'm so glad I'm memories from because in
the instant I talk about him because I'm
such an idiot
I spill everything that's going through
my head how it actually jeopardizes life
but I don't know he is so we're safe I
don't know where he's from so we're safe
except for Pakistan now he's born the
USA born in doesn't matter how do we do
that
how do we help how do we help people
that have a religion that's wrong but
that aren't going to kill us to be able
to be part of us without you know we see
in France we see in Belgium we see in
these places these these communities
that stay insular you know this man who
says to me that my community would kill
me these insular communities we've got
to get back to the idea of an America
that was a melting pot
we have to be able to have that guy that
talked to me after my lecture we got to
be able to have him just you know be
another guy and all of this this
long-winded the passionate craziness and
I'm spewing out with no answers just
comes down to we've got to stop judging
people but the color of their skin and
where they're from I mean did we learn
that with with the Irish didn't we learn
that with the Polish didn't we learn
that with the Africans didn't want to
learn that with every single group of
people that we spit on and not welcomed
I mean John Lennon said in a song called
New York City with the elephants memory
band if the man wants to shove us out
we're gonna jump and shout the Statue of
Liberty said come New York City such a
fucking bad-ass City yeah you know the
United States of America it's a fucking
bad-ass country and we are strong and we
are brave and we are loving and we've
got to stop acting like towers we've got
to stop acting like in every single
cupboard is a Muslim terrorist yes
terrorism is a problem yes we have to
protect our families yes the nightmare
of these deaths is is unforgivable and
unthinkable but we have to remember that
people are good if you look at the 7
billion people on this planet just about
7 billion of them are really good we can
really trust them can we please learn
something from Las Vegas learn something
about gambling right we know how the
odds work we know the house always wins
in this case the odds are always on
someone being good if someone walks up
to you with dark skin and straight hair
looking like they're from Pakistan or
Egypt or even you know even Iraq even
Afghanistan and
they're walking towards you the chances
are overwhelming that that person will
be good you're not trying to fill an
inside straight
the chances are way in your advantage
that they're good people so how do by
atheism change well there's no God and
there's never a doubt about that ever
but we have to make sure that when we're
screaming that there's no God
we don't scream it so loud that we can't
hear someone who is religious crying for
help and know that we have to help them
[Music]